HE'S ALSO DEFENDING HIS ACTIONS
ON TWITTER.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS HAS SPECIFICS.
>> THE SPRING SNOWSTORM CANCELED
THE PRESIDENT'S SCHEDULE BUT IT
DIDN'T AFFECT HIS TWITTER FEED
ONE PET.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAKING NO
APOLOGIES FOR CONGRATULATING
VLADIMIR PUTIN ON HIS ELECTION
VICTORY.
I CALLED PRESIDENT PUTIN OF
RUSSIA TO CONGRATULATE HIM ON
HIS ELECTION VICTORY AND PAST
OBAMA CALLED HIM ALSO.
A FAKE NEWS MEDIA IS CRAZED
BECAUSE THEY WANT ME TO
EXCORIATE HIM.
THEY ARE WRONG.
GETTING ALONG WITH RUSSIA AND
OTHERS IS A GOOD THING, NOT A
BAD THING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT ON TO SAY,
RUSSIA CAN HELP SOLVE
INTERNATIONAL CRISES, AND HE
CRITICIZED PRESIDENT BUSH FOR
NOT HAVING THE SMARTS TO GET
ALONG WITH RUSSIA, OBAMA AND
CLINTON FOR NOT HAVING THE
ENERGY OR CHEMISTRY TO DO IT.
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS CHIEF OF
STAFF ARE ALSO HOT ABOUT THE
LEAK OF A CLASSIFIED
PRESIDENTIAL BRIEFING MEMO ON
THE PUTIN PHONE CALL.
JOHN KELLY SAID TO BE FRUSTRATED
AND DISAPPOINTED, SOMEWHAT
LEAKED THAT THE MEMO HAD "DO NOT
CONGRATULATE" IN ALL CAPS AT THE
TOP.
ON CAPITOL HILL, A CRITICISM OF
THE PRESIDENT CONGRATULATED
BRUTON BUT MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT WEEK.
>> I DON'T LIKE WHAT YOU DID BUT
I REALLY HATE THAT SOMEONE IN
HIS INNER CIRCLE IS GOING TO
LEAK THIS STUFF.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE WORKING FOR
THE PRESIDENT, YOU SHOULD
RESIGN.
>> WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS TELL
FOX NEWS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
MAY HAVE NEVER SEEN THE MEMO AND
ITS WARNING.
THE CALLS A PERSON WAS MADE
EARLY FROM THE RESIDENCE.
JUST PRIOR TO US, H.R. MCMASTER
AND OTHERS BRIEFED THE PRESIDENT
BY PHONE COMING OUT IN PERSON.
FOX NEWS HAS     WAS TOLD DURING
FOX NEWS HAS     WAS TOLD DURINT
FOX NEWS HAS     WAS TOLD DURINA
CONFERENCE CALL, THE DO NOT
CONGRATULATE POINT AND NEVER
CAME UP.
SOURCES SAY WHILE THE MEMO WAS
IN THE PRESIDENT'S DAILY
BRIEFING BOOKS, HE MAY NOT HAVE
SEEN A NEED TO READ IT SINCE HE
WAS ALREADY BRIEFED.
THE SENATOR JERRY COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN SAYS HE LIKELY WOULDN'T
HAVE CALLED.
NOT ALL.
>> I THINK PUTIN IS A CRIMINAL.
WHAT HE DID IN GEORGIA, WHAT HE
DID IN UKRAINE, WHAT HE HAS DONE
IN LONDON, POISONING PEOPLE WITH
NERVE GAS.
THAT IS A CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
>> THE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR, A
FIERCE CRITIC OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP, SAID TODAY, HE
BELIEVES THE PRESIDENT IS AFRAID
OF CRITICIZING PUTIN.
>> THE RUSSIANS MAY HAVE
SOMETHING ON HIM PERSONALLY THAT
THEY CAN ALWAYS ROLL OUT AND
MAKE IT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO TOOK AIM
AT THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
TODAY.
IN A TWEED COAT AND
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW EXPERT ALAN
DERSHOWITZ'S AGREEMENT WITH THE
PRESIDENT THAT MULLER SHOULD
HAVE NEVER BEEN APPOINTED.
>> I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
RIGHT WHEN HE SAID THERE NEVER
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A SPECIAL
COUNSEL APPOINTED BECAUSE THERE
WAS NO PROPER CAUSE.
>> ONE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
BIGGEST SUPPORTERS ON
CAPITOL HILL WENT SO FAR AS TO
SAY MUELLER SHOULD BE GONE.
>> HE'S DONE ENOUGH DAMAGE.
HE NEEDS TO GO.
I'M NOT CALLING FOR HIM TO BE
FIRED BECAUSE OF ALL THE
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS THAT
THINK THEY'D HAVE TO COME OUT
FOR TRUMP IF HE WERE FIRED.
>> SOME BIG NEWS EXPECTED TO
COME OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
TOMORROW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP EXPECTED TO
ANNOUNCE NEW TARIFFS, THIS TIME
AIMED SPECIFICALLY AT CHINA.
THESE ARE BEING CALLED
PROTECTIVE COVER NOT PUNITIVE
TARIFFS COME AT US DESIGNED TO
RECOVER DAMAGES FROM WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAYS OUR CHINESE
UNFAIR TRADE PRACTICES.
THEY WOULD BE AIMED AT A NUMBER
OF GOODS AND CODE TOTAL
$30 MILLION OR MORE.
THE PRESIDENT IS ALSO EXPECTED
TO ANNOUNCE INVESTMENT
RESTRICTIONS IN U.S.
TECHNOLOGICAL COMPANIES.
IT'S BELIEVED THAT CHINA HAS
TRIED TO CAPTURE THE TECHNICAL
LOGICAL INDUSTRIES THE FUTURE.
2017 U.S. CHINA COMMISSION
REPORT RECOMMENDED THAT THE
UNITED STATES RESTRICT
INVESTMENT BY CHINESE OWNED OR